[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy Kaiser machmood a Muslim born in
Pakistan is the new head of the Swedish
national heritage board now this is very
strange
since kaiser mahmoud readily admits that
he's not read anything about Sweden's
cultural heritage but his new job is not
really about preserving and protecting
Sweden's cultural heritage and
historical sites at all Kaiser Mahmoud
who once wrote his motorcycle around
Sweden in apparent in an apparently
failed attempt to discover what being
Swedish consisted of is using his
position as head of the Swedish national
heritage board not to highlight and
celebrate that heritage which is what
that job is supposed to be about but to
downplay Sweden's cultural heritage in
history and to create a false narrative
that will help compel sweets to accept
mass Muslim migration he says he doesn't
want simply to alert people to Viking
artifacts and the like but to use
Sweden's history to create the narrative
that will make Muslim migrants part of
something now we've already seen how
this works remember recently the fake
news story about the Viking burial cloth
bearing the word Allah last October a
Swedish researcher gained international
headlines by claiming that burial
costumes from Viking graves dating back
to the 9th and 10th centuries had been
found to be inscribed with the name
Allah the intent of this was obvious to
convince Swedes that Islam had always
been a part of Sweden all the way back
to the days of the Vikings and so they
should not be concerned about the mass
Muslim migration that was now bringing
Sweden unprecedented rape and other
crime rates Islam has always been a part
of Sweden stop opposing mass Muslim
migration it's racist to do so the
Viking burial cloths didn't really
feature the name Allah at all
Stephanie Mulder is an associate
professor of medieval Islamic art and
archaeology at the University of Texas
at Austin and she proved that the Viking
burial clause did not bear the name
Allah shortly after the international
head
that they did but by then the damage had
been done the idea had entered however
dimly the popular consciousness the
Vikings were really Muslims as long as
Swedish Swedish was Islamic before it
was Christian the Muslim migrants are
Swedes the hola Viking burial cloth
propaganda offensive was one
manifestation of what Kaiser machmood
and others like him are doing there is
no Muslim history in Sweden but Kaiser
Mahmoud is working to change the very
idea of cultural heritage and fabricate
fictions about a historical Muslim
presence in Sweden in order to advance
his political and sociological agenda
Kaiser machmood as a Pakistani is of
course not Swedish and he has no Swedish
heritage and his admitted lack of
knowledge of Swedish heritage and
history ought to have disqualified him
from his position but this is how Sweden
is obliterating itself and committing
cultural and national suicide after all
it was Swedes who appointed Kaiser
Mahmoud to this position it is Swedish
leaders who want to destroy Swedish
cultural and national identity it also
must be remembered in connection with
Kaiser machmood role as head of the
Swedish national heritage board that the
Koran suggests that ruins are a sign of
a laws punishment of those who rejected
him the Quran says many were the ways of
life that have passed away before you
travel through the earth and see what
was the end of those who rejected truth
that's chapter 3 verse 137 this is one
of the foundations of the Islamic idea
that pre-islamic civilizations and non
Islamic civilizations are all jacquelina
the Society of unbelievers which is
worthless trash
obviously this cuts against the idea of
tourism of ancient sites and non-muslim
religious installations such as are
found all over Sweden the great novelist
VS Naipaul encountered this attitude in
his travels through Muslim countries for
many Muslims he observed he said the
time before Islam is a time of blackness
that is part of his Muslim theology
history has to serve theology Naipaul
recounted that some Pakistani Muslims
far from valuing the nations renowned
archaeological site at mohenjo-daro saw
its ruins
teaching opportunity for Islam
recommending that that passage of the
Koran be posted there is a teaching tool
it does lead one to ponder what Keyser
Mahmoud might allow to be done or not
done with Sweden's historical sites and
artifacts but whatever destruction may
ensue is obviously exactly what Swedish
authorities want
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]